hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Gotham episode 11 video just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet it was the mid-season
finale they teased a couple really big
comic book characters that are coming so
right off the bat I'll just say mr.
freeze and Hugo Strange were the big
teases at the end of the episode I know
we went to that Indian Hills research
facility that's owned by Wayne
Enterprises and there were a couple
other people in Tanks those were not the
real teases it was all about Hugo
Strange doing something with Theo's body
that was why the nurse said he has high
hopes for this one yeah we don't know
who Theo is gonna be turned into but the
teases is that Hugo Strange is going to
turn him into a metahuman and bring him
back because it seems like the order of
st. Dumas storyline is over and they
tease court of owls just with Bruce st.
you know like an owl is my favorite
animal it sounds like Theo might be able
to come back as a talent we don't know
if that's the case though because Hugo
Strange would have to be connected to
the court of owls for that to happen so
until we get further evidence just
assume Theo is going to come back
looking like some sort of nightmare top
5 WTF though starting with Alfred gets
thrown in the dump literally as hardcore
as this character is he was total comedy
in this episode it was perfect Sean
Pertwee is amazing a comedy not my face
not my beautiful face they wind up
throwing to the barns arc where he won't
go after Theo because he's worried that
a judge is gonna throw the evidence out
and Theo will walk away Barnes was not
much of a character in Sep so he was
more of a speed bump for the characters
to jump over paint penguin literally
jumps over him after he knocks him out
so Barnes obviously coming back next
season but the whole point of Alfred
showing up at the police station was so
they could just be like look seriously
probable cause dude Theo is clearly
trying to do something to the Wayne
family on a my number 4 WTF everyone
gangs up on the Riddler another great
comedy moment there were so many funny
moments in this episode despite so much
WTF stuff happening he's so taken aback
by Bullock jumping up on him that he
tells them a riddle just as a defense
mechanism which Lucius Fox decodes
freakin Riddler out even more
Grundy number 805 big Easter Egg there
obviously for Solomon Grundy but
Detective Comics number 805 was a big
mr. freeze Clayface story so I don't
know if Clayface is coming but obviously
mr. freeze showed up at the end of this
episode they talked about Clayface
coming on the show in the past but I
don't know if it's actual
happen I'm not gonna believe it till I
see it I know my number 3 WTF Bruce and
silver drag the whole episode down so
this is actually it's kind of a negative
WTF one of my few criticisms against the
episode is that the pacing was perfect
like that third act was amazing when the
Catwoman shows up at Riddler's that
whole scene was amazing if the whole
show could find a way to maintain that
level of energy I feel like it'd be
perfect but jumping from scenes like
that - these Bruce Silver scenes just
felt completely uneven now obviously
this is all about humanizing silvers
character showing that Bruce isn't
afraid to die I'll be reunited with my
family
elves are my favorite animal and I think
he just drains the episode but I do I do
think that it's necessary like you do
have to have this moment with Bruce but
if you want a really good example of a
scene weird like a character is waiting
to go to the gallows waiting for an
execution rewatch Game of Thrones season
1 when Ned Stark gets thrown in the
black cells and he's talking to Varys or
you could actually if you go a couple
seasons later in Game of Thrones when
Tyrion gets thrown in the black cells
and he's talking to Jaime and various
characters those are great scenes with
characters reflecting on their life
waiting to die just because the
character is sitting stationary in a
Cell doesn't mean it can't be really
high-energy and intense on a my number
two WTF as I mentioned though Catwoman
shows up at nygma's and everything
starts to explode Gordon is rolling out
on the warpath and Leah's pregnant
apparently so there's so much to unpack
from the scene one there's the easter
egg from Catwoman what are you a Martian
in a rubber suit nice Martian Manhunter
Easter Egg then we have a Barbara Gordon
teaser like is that who this baby is
gonna turn out to be I know that in the
comics Lee Thompkins never married Jim
Gordon but these actors in real life
Morena Baccarin and Ben McKenzie are
really actually having a baby together
in real life so Morena Baccarin probably
gonna stay on the show for season 3 so I
think it's completely acceptable for
them to bend canon to get to Barbara
Gordon who will be Batgirl someday they
get completely taken into different
direction she just announced that she's
pregnant and she doesn't look that
praying on-screen so there's a whole lot
of Batman stuff that has to happen
before we can get to Batgirl I will
completely lose my [ __ ] though if they
named that baby Barbara that's as she
could pull the take obviously Barbara
Gordon is Batgirl that has to be
Gordon's daughter but what do you think
Lee will say when Gordon tries to name
their baby after the crazy
woman they tried to kill him that he
used to be in a relationship with
something tells me she's not gonna be
super excited to name that baby Barbara
you do have to give Lea some credit in
this episode though she's not like your
prototypical Godfather wife Leigh Corden
doesn't give her the don't ask me about
my business line she totally understands
what he has to do just call me when you
can and she accepts his proposal the
funny thing about this scene there with
them sitting at the end of the episode
is that if you live in New York you know
this is like right in Central Park I've
actually been to that place it's either
part of the Met or the American History
Museum depending on which side of the
park they're on I can't quite remember
they're like there's somewhere in the
middle of the park for those that don't
know Gotham is one of the few shows
that's actually shot in New York City
most TV shows are shot in Los Angeles
but sometimes they'll shoot in Atlanta
like walking dead sometimes they'll
shoot in New York like a lot of the
Marvel Netflix shows and of course Donna
my number one WTF theos body is taken to
the secret Wayne Enterprises facility
that's experimenting on people with
powers or trying to give people powers
professor Hugo Strange is in charge and
then mr. free shows up unannounced
in a post-credits scene now this is
Victor freeze that's what he'll be
called on the TV show now for those that
don't know BD Wong is the actor that's
playing Hugo Strange
he's been posting pictures of himself
doing makeup tests with the beard so he
will be full-blown comic book Hugo
Strange now the character typically
shows up through Arkham
he works at Arkham with the criminally
insane so I'm hoping that this
intersects with Barbara's arc because I
totally dig the character when she's
being super crazy the crazier the better
but it seems like they're really leaning
into this secret Indian Hills facility
so I'm hoping the show doesn't
completely abandoned Arkham but we know
that Barbara is there so they have to go
back at some point mr. Freeze's a little
bit more of a question mark in terms of
story arcs because he has this full
ColdGear
looks like he's trying to kill this dude
but we don't know why if you want to
watch some really good mr. freeze
stories watch the animated series watch
Batman the Animated Series if the
producers do any interviews explaining
what's going on with these characters
and the story auctions are gonna have
I'll be sure to do videos for that stuff
but just across the board I will say
Gotham season two so far way better than
season 1 they made a lot of improvements
I feel like a lot of the characters are
still caricatures and not real
characters themselves so there's still a
lot of work that they have to do like
you have to be able to connect with the
characters understand why they're doing
what they're doing like vo has this line
when tabatha turns on him and he says
that's such a ridiculous cliche I don't
even know you anymore even we don't know
as the audience what Theo used to be
like so the moment between Tabitha and
Theo isn't meaningful at all
one of my few criticisms against the
show but you guys let me know like what
was your favorite mom from the episode
but what about the moment where Gordon
actually ends up killing Theo or at
least it seems like he's dead he might
be on the edge of death but I think
their intention was is for them to show
that Gordon was finishing him off like
he was crossing that line I will say I
definitely like the direction they're
taking the Gordon character I feel like
Ben McKenzie the actor does best when
he's doing like this crazy version of
Gordon I feel like when they try to play
it straight it's not very earnest and
like it comes across as feeling kind of
fake Barnes's character is a really good
example of that he suffers from the same
syndrome where it's like this is more of
a caricature does not feel like a real
character except when Barnes was telling
the story about how he blew up that
kid's head during the war that was like
the realest scene that Barnes had all
season that's a character moment the
rest of the time he feels kind of like a
stereotype but let me know what you guys
think of the first half of the season I
think everyone's in agreement that it's
way better than season 1 but I feel like
there's still a lot of things they could
do to improve the way that they do these
characters but the real big story
tonight is it it's the first half of the
flash arrow crossover new episode of the
flash so be sure to subscribe to get
that I'll post the video right after the
episode airs there is a new Batman V
Superman full trailer that is gonna post
on Wednesday night we got the teaser I
posted a video for it last night in case
you haven't seen it the full trailer
like way way longer is gonna come
Wednesday night so I'll totally do a
video for that too
why you guys wait for a flash arrow
crossover Batman V Superman stuff to
post you can click here for the teaser
video from last night crazy evil
Superman teaser and you can click here
to get ready for the flash arrow
crossover thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you